[Music]
chemistry gives answers to many queries
it acts as a bridge between the
theoretical concepts and the practical
world however where does chemistry get
all the answers from how do the
reactions change everything around us so
drastically well the answers are stored
inside the small nuclei of atoms yes
the tiny nucleus inside every atom is
like a treasure box
it holds the mystery of several
reactions now the next question to pop
in our mind is how does the nucleus of a
single atom define the reactions in
which the atom is participating that's
right it's the subatomic particles in
the nucleus the protons and the neutrons
that are the influencing factors yes the
presence and the number of protons and
neutrons in the nucleus of any atom
define many important characters like
the atomic number atomic mass isotopic
forms and so on wait a second do we know
what these are what do we mean by atomic
number how is it different from the
atomic mass and what exactly are
isotopes let's begin with the atomic
number first atomic number is denoted by
the letter Z as the name suggests atomic
number means the number assigned to a
particular atom now I want you to take
on what basis should an atom be assigned
a number should it be on the basis of
when the atom was discovered or on the
basis of how much quantity of the
element is present in nature what factor
can be applied for numbering the atoms
or the elements in general one promising
way is by numbering based on the number
of protons present inside the nucleus of
the atom yes it's because the atom of
every element has fixed number of
protons in its nucleus and this number
is unique to every element right what do
we mean by this for example any atom of
oxygen always has eight protons in its
nucleus no other element has at
with eight protons in it that means the
number of protons in the nucleus of an
atom is like the identity of that
element so can we number the atoms or
elements based on the number of protons
in the atomic nucleus yes this is how
atomic numbers are defined atomic number
in simple words is the number of protons
present in the nucleus of the atom why
do we need an atomic number by the way
the atomic number helps in defining the
characteristics of the element and why
so just think about it we know that the
number of electrons is equal to the
number of protons in an atom we also
know that the number of electrons will
determine the valency and does the
reactive capacity of an atom so now can
we connect the dots yes the
characteristics of elements will include
a few properties and these properties
will be based on the reactivity of the
atoms right we also note that the
reactivity depends on the number of
electrons present in the atoms and the
number of electrons is the same as the
number of protons so this is why the
characteristics of atoms are largely
dependent on the atomic number that is
the reason the atomic number or simply
the number of protons is important to us
well we know that atoms are the
fundamental units of every matter so can
you guess what could the size of a
single atom be and do all the atoms of
different elements have the same atomic
size let's study the concept of atomic
size in detail in the next video
[Music]
you